how did three Petty criminals launch a
business Empire land a Guinness World
Record and become hallucinations of
themselves it all started in a little
place called Sunnyvale
while it may appear that the show's
Central trailer park has always looked
the same the first four seasons of
trailer park boys were filmed at
different locations across Nova Scotia
Canada due to complaints by the
residents the boys were supposedly
forced out of these parks and eventually
opted to purchase and build their own
set in Dartmouth this is the park which
fans started seeing from season five
onwards it's terrible situation of
course the spin-off series out of the
park sees the characters Ricky Julian
and Bubbles going on adventurous making
stops in Europe and the United States
but while the trio have gone
International the true home of the boys
is their eponymous trailer park
there's been plenty of speculation
surrounding the departure of Jonathan
torrance's J-Rock from the show Torrance
announced his departure via Twitter on
April 20th 2016 and later said in his
podcast Taggart and Torrance I
ultimately felt that I had achieved all
that I could with J-Rock but he's been
in my head and part of my existence for
so long it's weird although fans would
love to see their favorite rapper drop
more bars at Park concerts tauren's
insists he gave the role everything he
had
the Show's theme song is tranquil and
gives fans a peaceful view of the park
before the f-bombs and complete comedic
chaos takes over it was directly
influenced by singer Tony Bennett's
signature song I Left My Heart in San
Francisco which peaked at number 19 on
the Billboard Hot 100 when originally
released in 1962 and in 2001 the tune
peaked at number one in the hearts of
Trailer Park Boys fans when I Left My
Heart in San Francisco was adapted by
Blaine Morris into the theme song Breeze
although fans probably prefer calling it
simply the trailer park boys theme song
from Bennett to Morris the song has and
will always be a classic
while it can be more rewarding to watch
a continuous overarching story from
start to finish since audiences get to
see character development minor story
arcs and the plot payoff Trailer Park
Boys is meant to be episodic people
should be able to watch any episode and
still understand what's happening if you
come back short you're going to be
responsible do you understand me that's
stupid Julian yes you are stupid that's
why I have to tell you this these are
the running jokes that any Die Hard fan
will appreciate such as Randy's shirt
allergy but a first-time viewer should
be able to watch any episode and
understand the plot but episodic or not
watching the show in chronological order
allows viewers to better understand the
characters on the surface the boys are
just criminals who routinely come up
with small-minded plans break laws and
wind up in jail but as episodes build on
one another Ricky Julian Bubbles and the
rest of the park residents become more
charismatic redeemable and root Worthy
Jimmy Buffett has Margaritaville Mark
Wahlberg has Wahlburgers and Bubbles had
bubbles Mansion Unfortunately they had
to close their doors in 2010 according
to CBC manager Brad Hartland said the
Halifax bar could no longer compete
because students stopped coming once
legislation forced minimum drink prices
up from one dollar to two dollars and
fifty cents although eight Liquor
Control Act violations had also hit
their other bar the toothy moose
Portland claimed the closing of bubble's
Mansion wasn't related to these legal
troubles no matter the reasoning Trailer
Park Boys was and still is famous enough
for their characters to open a bar in
their name
the characters Jim and Barbara Leahy had
a daughter named Trina though she didn't
make many appearances throughout the
series they might recognize her as the
now famous actor Elliot page while Paige
has gone on to star in major Hollywood
projects like Juno Inception and the
Umbrella Academy he walked onto the
Trailer Park Boys said as an unknown and
left as a beloved character would you be
upset if your mom and Sam broke up would
Randy be upset if you gave him a double
cheeseburger Trina would visit Mr Leahy
in the Summers and befriended Ricky
despite her father telling her to stay
away from him and Julian while Paige
only appeared in a few episodes in
season two Trina has mentioned
affectionately throughout the series
John dunsworth who played the fan
favorite character Jim Leahy passed away
from an unexpected illness at 71 years
old in 2017. his daughter Sarah
dunsworth Nickerson who also plays the
character of Sarah on the show announced
the sad news of her father's passing via
Twitter on October 16 2017. the Tweet
read with heavy and broken hearts the
family of John F dunsworth would like to
let people know that our amazing husband
father and grandfather John dunsworth
has passed away John left this world
peacefully after a short and unexpected
illness after dunsworth's death the
season 12 finale concluded with a
heartfelt tribute to dunsworth as well
as some Eerie words from Mr Leahy when
you're dead you're dead
but you're not quite so dead
if you contribute something in the first
episode of Trailer Park Boys the
Animated Series Mr Leahy is carried off
by a hawk which is probably the perfect
ending to a character who has always
been dropping isms related to Hawks
Donnie the neighbor who's always
screaming off camera at the boys might
sound familiar that's because the
character is the voice of Mike Smith
while Donnie might appear to unleash a
whole lot of unnecessary rip roaring
monologues he sometimes does it for good
reason
honey what's your language their
children in this park instead of being a
wordless bystander Donnie takes direct
action by yelling uncontrollably at loud
noises such as crashing cars and
gunshots we've all got a Breaking Point
and sometimes a person just wants peace
and quiet while Donnie is finally seen
on camera in season 12 his face is
blurred out his voice which could use a
bar of soap or two is still performed by
Smith
while Julian always wears the same
outfit of a black shirt and blue jeans
usually while holding a rum and cook
Ricky wearing the same exact shirt
throughout each season is to a different
effect even ending up ripped or duct
taped in some Seasons while Ricky does
change his clothes the running joke is
that he has an extremely limited number
of shirts usually using one shirt per
season keeps this joke rolling and the
wear and tear give his wardrobe that
authentic Ricky really only does have a
few shirts feel
it may be hard today to believe Trailer
Park Boys originally ended after seven
seasons when Netflix took over in 2014
they added five more seasons as well as
specials an animated series and multiple
feature-length films the Netflix deal
came on the heels of Wells Tremblay and
Smith acquiring the rights to the show
from original producers Mike clattenberg
Barry Dunn and Mike Volpe in a statement
clattenberg claimed while the three of
us have moved on to different TV and
film projects the boys are the only ones
with the intimate knowledge and love of
the show to keep Trailer Park Boys Alive
and Well not only has Netflix helped
bring new life to TPB but they have
brought the show to a vastly wider
audience
swearnet created by Wells Tremblay and
Smith features the entire world of
Trailer Park Boys and has become a true
business Empire creating its own beer
whiskey and much more he said he was
really impressed with the customer
service fear is going great man people
are loving it yeah and he wants more the
website features clips of the Trailer
Park Boys family doing what they do best
as well as Clips capturing Wells
Tremblay and Smith out of character plus
it even has its own movie titled
swearnet the movie which holds the
current Guinness world record for the
most uses of the f word in movie history
creating an animated spin-off of a
pre-existing live-action television
series is nothing new Star Trek and the
Canadian Comedy Corner guest turn to
cartoons to tell stories that would have
been difficult with their flesh and
blood actors to this end in 2019 Trailer
Park Boys the Animated Series debuted on
Netflix as a direct follow-up to the
original series which had just completed
its 12th season according to the court
the franchise going animated was an
in-universe plot development choice at
the end of season 12 a gaggle of
characters were arrested for
participating in a drug smuggling
operation right after they collectively
consumed pounds of magic mushrooms as
the hallucinogenic effects of those
mushrooms kick in the characters start
to see themselves and their world as a
giant cartoon additionally transitioning
to an animated format allowed the
production to address the death of John
dunsworth that producers opted to
initially keep Mr Leahy alive in the
Animated Series constructing his
dialogue from old voice lines recorded
for episodes of the live action series
Trailer Park Boys was one of those early
series which helped Pioneer the
mockumentary format in comedic
television well before the office Modern
Family or Abbott Elementary the Canadian
series aimed to produce a seemingly
realistic look at life of petty
criminals in a Trailer Park Community
the characters were acutely aware of the
cameras in their faces and would comment
on how they were being filmed for a
documentary according to the Globe and
Mail to keep this idea going the three
main stars of the show rarely appear in
public or give interviews out of
character or out of costume I'm bobbles
I'm Julian
am I I'm Ricky but my passport says
Randy Leahy so I'm not really sure who I
am Smith Wells and Tremblay have
received Awards appeared on talk shows
and performed live as their trailer park
boys personas they refused to break
character in behind the scenes footage
available as DVD extras and in 2019 the
trio set sail on a Trailer Park Boys
themed Cruise playing their roles for
five straight days while mingling with
fans
the titular trailer park Trio might be
Petty near do Wells but off screen the
franchise's actors and creative forces
have used their popularity and influence
to push for social and legislative
change in May 2021 Wells Smith and
Tremblay starred in a 52nd public
service announcement for Nova scotia's
Department of Health titled part of our
way forward where they advocate for
getting the kobit 19 vaccination in
March 2022 the boys produced and posted
to Twitter a video to bring awareness to
the issue of poor quality drinking water
and Indigenous Canadian communities
government just fix the indigenous water
problem which it's not that hard please
exist please
according to HuffPost back in 2016 the
Nova Scotia government did away with the
tax credit that encouraged films and TV
shows to shoot in the province since the
TPB production was a beneficiary of that
program the boys waged the hashtag save
Sunnyvale campaign on social media and
protest Smith made a video as bubbles
warning audiences that their show could
possibly end without these Financial
advantages and Days Later a 10 million
dollar production fund was established
reportedly 810 000 of this fund went to
fund season 10 of Trailer Park Boys
the show's Canadian pride is often
reflected in the music used throughout
the franchise a lot of the needle drops
go to some of Canada's most successful
acts such as Rush The Tragically Hip and
April Wine some Canadian music legends
have even physically appeared on Trailer
Park Boys projects Randy cheated he
stole his answer that's right Alex I'm a
way bigger fan in the name you're the
best guitar player that ever lived per
the CBC in 2003 the primary Trio served
as an opening act on a package tour with
Canadian bands Finger 11 and Our Lady
Peace and in 2017 quebec-based EDM
artist Mark Mysteria remixed bubble
signature folk tune Mike Smith has also
popped up as bubbles in videos by rap
reggae artist snow and rock band The
Tragically Hip according to sleaze rocks
in 2019 the boys staged a full-length
concert at the hair in the fair Festival
in Welland Ontario assisted by Canadian
hair metal figure Sebastian Bach of skid
row this wasn't too surprising as Bach
has appeared as himself on multiple
Trailer Park Boys projects
Trailer Park Boys isn't just a single
show evolving through several formats
with new methods after seven seasons on
Canada's showcase Network the feature
films countdown to Liquor day and Don't
Legalize It were produced and then
released in Canadian movie theaters in
2009 and 2014 respectively Bridging the
original show with the Netflix series
Revival in 2014 after 50 more episodes
on the streaming service Trailer Park
Boys evolved into two seasons worth of
the animated series and then returned to
live action with Trailer Park Boys jail
distributed by swearnet the 2021 series
of 10 episodes finds the criminally
mischievous Ricky Julian and bubbles in
a familiar Place prison but this time
it's a semi-permanent situation while
the trio usually don't leave the
Sunnyvale Trailer Park they're
prohibited from leaving the Sunnyvale
Correctional Facility where it's
considerably harder for them to get up
to their usual shenanigans
[Music]
thank you